Not even death could keep Picard from coming
back for season 2.
The "Star Trek" universe continues to boldly
go where no show has gone before — sort
of — as it follows Jean-Luc Picard years
after his adventures on the Starship Enterprise.
The first season sees the former admiral investigate
the truth behind Data's daughter and a new
breed of synthetic beings.
His mission takes him across the universe,
even revisiting his time with the Borg, while
also dealing with a sinister Romulan plot.
There's also the small problem that Picard
is dying of Irumodic Syndrome, a degenerative
condition that slowly robs him of his memory.
It's an action-packed season that ends as
Dr. Agnes Jurati transfers Picard's consciousness
into a synthetic body.
Don't worry — this doesn't mean he's immortal.
The body has been programmed to expire around
the same time Picard would've died naturally.
So that's ... good?
Anyway, from there, the universe is Picard's
oyster since he has the crew of La Sirena
to go on more adventures with.
But "Picard" Season 2 will up the stakes for
the show's sophomore season, with the extra-dimensional
being known as Q returning to break the universe
as one final task for the series' namesake hero.
The season throws Picard and his crew back
into the 21st century to see how they save
the future — if anyone can fix the fabric
of reality, it's the former captain of the
Enterprise, that's for sure.
But what do fans need to know about "Picard"
Season 2?
First things first: The good news is that
"Picard" Season 2 is heading to our screens
very soon.
It will arrive on Paramount+ on March 3rd.
There's a total of 10 episodes this season,
so it's keeping the story quite tight compared
to the 20+-episode-long seasons of "Star Trek:
The Next Generation."
The second season will end on May 5th, but
it's not going to be the end of "Picard" — Paramount
worked back-to-back on Season 2 and the final,
third season.
So what does this mean for the adventure to
come?
Well, according to StarTrek.com, Q's final
trial will force the La Sirena crew to confront
the perils of 21st-century Earth.
It seems likely that this threat will bleed
into the third season in some way, considering
Paramount worked on both seasons at the same
time.
Showrunner Terry Matalas told SFX that there
are some "legendary moments" ahead.
It's worth noting that although "Picard" Season
2 starts airing on March 3rd, the third season
doesn't have an official release date just
yet.
But Deadline previously reported that Paramount
is aiming for 2023.
Unsurprisingly, Patrick Stewart is coming
back to play Jean-Luc Picard, or should we
say, the synthetic version of Picard.
He'll also be joined by Santiago Cabrera,
who plays Cristóbal Rios, the captain of
the La Sirena.
Alison Pill will reprise her role as Dr. Agnes
Jurati, although thankfully, her scheming
days are over after her heroic turn midway
through the first season.
Michelle Hurd is also coming back as Picard's
confidante, Raffi Musiker, while Isa Briones
will return as fellow synthetic-being Soji.
Rounding out the La Sirena crew is Evan Evagora
as warrior monk Elnor.
Original "Next Generation" star Brent Spiner
is also set to return as scientist Dr. Altan
Inigo Soong, "Voyager" star Jeri Ryan will
step into Seven of Nine's shoes again, and
Orla Brady will continue to appear as Laris,
Picard's Romulan housekeeper.
But the guest stars of "Picard" Season 2 are
interesting too.
Whoopi Goldberg will play the diplomatic Guinan
again, offering counsel to Picard when he
needs it most.
On the villain side of things, John de Lancie
will cause havoc for the gang as Q, and Annie
Wersching will replace Alice Krige as the
Borg Queen.
Remember, Picard has dabbled with the Borg
in the past.
He was assimilated into the hive as Locutus
of Borg.
So it'll be interesting to see how the Borg
Queen reacts to seeing him again after several decades.
Paramount+ released a full two-minute-long
look at "Picard" Season 2 on Star Trek Day 2021.
The footage shows Jean-Luc wandering around
his vineyard, reminiscing about his childhood
days, while narration from Q explains that
the trial he subjected humanity to all the
way back in "The Next Generation" season 1
never ended.
From there, the action really gets going,
with Rios and the La Sirena crew realizing
that Q has changed the past so that the world
has been transformed into a "totalitarian nightmare."
It's a far cry away from the idealized future
of Starfleet and the Federation, that's for sure.
The crew already knows that time's been altered
because Seven of Nine instantly realizes that
she has no Borg parts on her face anymore.
Clearly, the fascist regime cut the Borg off
at the knees.
The gang meets up with the Borg Queen, using
her technology to teleport to the past in
an attempt to fix whatever Q did to the timeline.
It's not exactly a new idea — Kirk and the
original Enterprise crew travel to the 20th
century in "Star Trek IV: The Voyage Home"
— but hopefully, the writers of "Picard"
find inventive ways of pushing these characters
further than the typical fish-out-of-water comedy.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.